hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast pediatric cancer genomics
accessing data tools and visualizations
in st. Jude cloud the team from st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital with
speakers for this event we are excited
to bring you this education webinar
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking site and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning this webinar is sponsored by
Microsoft a leading cloud solutions
provider empowering health organizations
and patient care in DNAnexus the leader
in cloud-based genome informatics and
data management the DNAnexus Microsoft
partnership enables the advancement of
genomic discovery through the sharing of
tools and datasets in a secure compliant
and collaborative ecosystem our work
accelerates scientific insights in
health care and research to solve the
largest challenges in the market today
I'm singer MA the scientific operations
director at DNAnexus
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the QA button
located in the bottom of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you're having any problems seeing or
hearing the presentation please click
the little support button at the top
right of the presentation window or use
the Q&A button to let us know that
you're having a problem this is an
educational webinars and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
C e button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits will start this webinar with a
quick introduction to the infrastructure
that powers the st. Jude cloud
development
ship between st. Jude Microsoft and
DNAnexus st. Jude cloud provides a
flexible cloud platform for rapid data
mining analysis and visualization
capabilities the st. Jude cloud platform
was built on top of DNAnexus and runs on
Microsoft Azure it is a customized view
and request system for st. Jude data and
offers the use of st. Jude tools st.
Jude cloud platform seeks not only to
provide a valuable data set but also the
cloud platform to allow in-place
analysis of the data to many of the
existing data access platforms simply
provide data and tools to download them
however this doesn't solve the core
problem of having multiple copies of
data and as data volumes grow this cost
increases st. Jude cloud platform is
more than just an FTP server providing
the underlying framework to perform
novel analysis the system also allows
for easy running of the st. Jude tools
on data which the user brings in
everybody has had the experience of
trying to use existing bioinformatics
tools go to a website download a zip
file then go to the arduous process of
installing things onto your system the
st. Jude cloud platform seeks to
simplify this whole process all it takes
is uploading your own data choosing
which tool you would like to use and
running it on DNAnexus all this is made
possible by the secure and compliant
system created by DNAnexus
allowing st. Jude to breathe easy and
not worry about these issues now I'd
like to introduce today's speakers the
team from st. Jude Children's Research
Hospital will share insight into how
they built the world's largest public
repository the pediatric cancer genomics
data we have Scott Newman PhD group lead
in bioinformatics and out analyst and
claim a cloud manager a bio info
software development please join me in
welcoming the first speaker Scott Newman
I will now turn the presentation over to
him
hi there everybody nice to meet you
my name is Scott Newman I'm a group lead
of bioinformatics analysis within the
department of computational biology at
st. Jude Children's Research Hospital
and later on you'll be hearing from my
colleague clay McLeod and manager on the
cloud project but first up we have
nothing to disclose we have no financial
relationships with companies that we
will mention in this webinar we aim to
introduce you to the st. Jude cloud what
is st. Jude cloud show you how you can
access data show you how you can run st.
you tools on your own data show you
briefly how to port your own tools into
the st. Jude cloud ecosystem to analyze
data and lastly show you how to use some
of the visualizations to gain insights
from the vast amount of data that we're
offering freely to the public so driving
all of this is our desire to share data
with the global research community st.
Jude is committed to sharing that data
as well committed to finding cures for
pediatric cancer and other rare and
catastrophic diseases of childhood and
we were among the first start sequencing
large numbers of whole genomes and whole
transcriptomes
with pediatric cancer genome project
which began almost ten years ago since
then we've done a lot more sequencing
namely with the three studies that I
list here the pediatric and genome
project the genomes for kids study where
we took whole genome sequencing into the
clinic and the st. Jude lifetime cohort
where we followed thousands of long-term
cancer survivors and also performed
whole genome sequencing on them as these
studies have been published we've always
shared the data with EGA and and DB gap
and other repositories and it's been
possible for researchers worldwide to
access the data through a data access
committee and then download the data
onto their local infrastructure and they
can run their analysis and that's been
fine for the past few years but now that
we're generating hundreds and thousands
of whole genome sequence
the data is getting so big that the old
model of data download is becoming
challenging and it also assumes that you
have sufficient infrastructure at your
institution to be able to house and
analyze this data a few years ago we we
started thinking that there was a better
way to do this what if you were to come
to the data what if you were to bring
your tools to the data and with that
idea that st. Jude Claire was born it's
taken three years now to get to where we
are and early on we considered the the
other cloud computing options out there
and decided whatever we came up with had
to be secure it had to be sustainable
and it had to be expandable and we're
now generating thousands of whole genome
sequences every year and we once share
those with the global research community
but to get there we had to get some help
from from the outside and first up in
2016 we selected a software development
partner and we went with DNAnexus
because that platform was highly secure
and we found that it was easy to develop
on we could move our tools to the
DNAnexus infrastructure relatively
easily and most importantly they were
excited to work with us next in 2017 we
partnered with Microsoft there are costs
associated with cloud computing and
storing all of these full genome
sequences terabytes and nearly a
petabyte of data currently we have and
would cost a lot of money were it not
for the the philanthropic gesture from
Microsoft and their housing all of our
whole genome data from the studies I
mentioned earlier at no cost within
Microsoft Azure and and between them the
partnership between st. Jude DNAnexus
and Microsoft make the st. Jude cloud
possible we launched in April of 2018
with our first 5,000 whole genome
sequences that we can offer to the
global research community and we've been
fulfilling data requests from April to
now
tambour so what does it look like
here is the st. Jude cloud WWC Jude
cloud hopefully that web address is easy
to remember and the website is split
into three sections data tools and
visualizations I'm a scientist I'm a
self-taught programmer so so really what
I want to do is get my hands on the data
run some sort of analysis tool on it and
look at the output I think many of us in
the the bioinformatics and computational
biology field can relate to that
workflow and what I'm going to do in the
subsequent slides and with clays help is
walk you through these three sections
and show you how you can gain access to
the data run the tools and look at the
visualizations within st. Jude cloud
platform so first up is data these
numbers are as of April 2018 we are
currently undergoing a big push to get
up to 10,000 whole genome sequences by
the end of 2018 currently there are over
5,000 whole genome sequences over 5,000
exomes and over 1,200 RNA sequences
these come from common and rare
pediatric tumors as well as much normal
tissue from the the tumor donors all of
these samples have been consented for
research data sharing importantly the
data set is also harmonized and we
remapped everything to the latest build
of the human genome grch38 using the
Microsoft genomics service gatk best
practices pipeline as I just said the
data is de-identified and it is
consented however this is genomics data
so so we're not giving it out for free
you know well free is maybe the wrong
word and the data access is protected
and we go through a data access
committee if you wish to gain access
you can select broadly based on study
for example the saint of life the
pediatric cancer
project genomes for kids are a clinical
pilot study but we've also tried to make
it easy to drill down into specific
samples of interest using our pecan
visualization portal and you can
identify the samples that you're
interested in for example high expresses
of jak2 and put them in your shopping
cart and submit that request to st. Jude
Cloud so here's what I was alluding to
earlier you must apply for access to raw
data and it is pediatric genomics data
but we've done our best to streamline
the data access procedure and all you
need to do is download a form and sign a
legally binding agreement if you don't
want to download the data if you want to
work with it exclusively in the cloud
then you're good to go
all you need to do is upload the form
and that form will be forwarded to our
data access committee and hopefully
they'll be able to grant you access
quickly if you do wish to download it
you need to get somebody from your
institution to sign off that you have
appropriate data security procedures in
place and the requisite amount of
storage now I realize that was a lot of
information so at this point I'm gonna
hand it over to my colleague clay McLeod
and he's gonna walk you through the data
identification request an access
procedure ok thanks Scott so what I'm
gonna do is walk through the data
section here first so if you guys didn't
see my screen I'm on st. Jude cloud
right now this is the home page so going
in and I'll click on data here we've got
you know if you've made previous
requests you can click here to go and
look at those previous requests but
we're gonna go in and explore the data
first so this is the site of the part of
the site that we followed the data
browser so there are three main ways by
which you can choose what samples you
want by the primary diagnosis here which
has all sorts of different information
and diseases by the publication so this
ties up with you know different PubMed
IDs and then also by this general
purpose data set tab so here are the
data sets that Scott's been talking
about here so we've got all of the data
from the pediatric cancer genome project
we've got the data from the clinical
pilot cohort where we piloted whole
genome whole exome and transcriptome
sequencing in the clinic we've got the
continuation of that which is the
genomes for kids project and then all of
the cancer survivorship study stuff
under the st. Jude live data set so the
process is relatively simple you just
tell us what samples you want here after
you tell us what samples you want you
tell us what type of files you want from
those samples and then you click request
data now on my screen here I actually
already have access to all of these so
since I was approved for access
previously I had submitted a data access
request I could just get the data now I
don't have to request access if you
haven't been through that before you
will have to request access by
downloading the PDF and everything so so
I've already done this though I'm going
to go through and I'll show you what
that request it's like in a second but
first I want to go back here really
quick to data and I want to show you how
to select data using pecan so pecan is
the pediatric cancer portal that we
develop here at st. Jude it's a lot of
visualizations that I think Scott's
going to talk about in a little bit but
you can do some really cool things here
so I'm gonna go through and look at my
favorite gene Jack - and this is I'm a
researcher this is gene I'm interested
in so you can see that here are point
mutations that we've seen in Jack you in
our pediatric cohort we have a graph
over here for rna-seq expression so I'm
going to focus on this just for the
purposes of this demonstration and I'm
gonna do a long tin transform here so
these are all of the samples that we've
seen that are loaded into pecan here and
we have low expresses of Jack - all the
way up to high expressives of Jack - so
let's say I'm a researcher I'm
interested in I want to look at all the
raw data for the high expresses of Jack
to that same Gpad so what I would do is
I would come here and I would select
these right and you can see a circle pop
up here that shows me the breakdown of
what are these samples like what type of
disease do they have you know things
like that
but actually something's interesting and
down here it says add 289 samples so
this is the add to cart' functionality
that Scott had talked about
previously you can click here and say I
want all of these camp samples to be
added to my part click my cart and then
I can submit a request to st. Jude cloud
here for all the samples that we have in
st. Jude cloud that match up in this
cohort so as you can see it's not all of
them today there's three hundred
seventy-six that I've selected here in
pecan and only two hundred eighty nine
of those are in the platform but we're
working to make that a one-to-one
relationship so I'm gonna step back here
and just show you the last bit which is
what if I've already made a data request
in st. Jude cloud so in that case I
would click manage data here and I've
already done some sample requests so
I'll show you the clinical ghent and
check out all of our clinical genomics
data on st. Jude cloud so I click this
and what it's going to do is it's going
to open up a new tab with gene in my DNA
next to the st. Jude cloud project
loaded I'm logged in okay so um so here
is a DNAnexus and Brandon's is a true
cloud branded DNAnexus project and we've
got all of the dams are going to be in
here it might take quite some time to
load because there are thousands and
thousands of dams yeah 3448 dams with
The Associated indices and then we've
also got G VCF files here so that's an
overview of data in st. Jude cloud and I
think with that I'm gonna kick it back
over to Scott you know walking through
tools you're back with me Scott moving
on to the next section of the website
tools many of us in bioinformatics are
frustrated how difficult it is to
install tools and get them up and
running on your data there's a big
problem with reproducibility and
bioinformatics and we're all aware of it
we all reap a person we think this tool
is really cool I want to run it on my
data I want to see what it gets and then
we waste days and months trying to
install the tool getting it to compile
getting appropriate libraries getting
white lists getting black lists and even
then there's no
guarantee that you can reproduce the the
data in the published study we've tried
to remove all of that pain by packaging
our tools into workflows that are easy
for a non bioinformatics specialist to
run somebody like a graduate student or
a postdoc or medical doctor can
hopefully run our tools with only a few
clicks of the mouse
and so we aim to make these tools easy
to use and and most of them also produce
an interactive visualization at the end
that you can explore currently on st.
Jude cloud we have our rapid RNA seek
pipeline this is a method to find fusion
genes in enhancers and a similar methods
being used in our clinical pipeline to
support one of our clinical trials we
make this tool available for research
use we also have to seek broad and
narrow peak calling neo epitope
prediction if you're interested in
immune oncology we have a differential
gene expression pipeline called worden
and we have our cancer predisposition
variant annotation and classification
system called pecan pie coming soon is
going to be a tool that will allow you
to unpick mutational signatures such as
UV or tobacco smoke damage from cancer
genomes and that should be coming out in
the next few months as I said earlier
it's our hope that only a few clicks
will allow a non specialist to run these
tools and get meaningful results out at
the end at this point I'm going to hand
it over to clay again to demo the rapid
RNA pipeline and actually have to get
your own data into st. Jude Cloud ok so
now we're going to take a look at tools
so as Scott was showing in the
presentation here is our list of the
tools that we make available in st. Jude
cloud today I'm gonna walk you through
rapid RNA speak which
Scott and I both worked on so when you
click on rapid RNA seek you're presented
with a view of its profile view of this
tool
we've got a nice icon out here but more
importantly we've got a lot of
information about the tool so who wrote
the tool you know if there's a
publication the inputs the outputs the
support of genome builds and then a
contact us button there is extensive
documentation if I click here on getting
started you can see that we've got a
page full of documentation telling you
about how to run the tool monitoring run
progress analysis of results known
issues and frequently asked questions
you also we can upload our data on this
tool so uploading data is pretty easy we
have an app called the st. Jude cloud
data transfer app that you can just
point and click so I'm going to click
here to open app and and it's going to
open up the st. Jude cloud desktop data
transfer app on my computer you can see
that it has pre-loaded here my rapid RNA
seek project this is the area where
we're going to be running rapid RNA seek
in the cloud and and uploading your data
is pretty simple
oops uploading your data is pretty
simple you just take the files on your
desktop here drag them over and then you
click upload and those will be
transported beamed up to the cloud into
your secure cloud environment so so
that's how you upload data I'm going to
show you where that data went here in
just a second I'm back on this page and
I'm going to click launch tool select
the preset so I had uploaded you know a
pair of fast queue files so I'm going to
select that and I get dropped into my
st. Jude branded DNAnexus project with
this workflow open so you can see
there's a lot of steps here here a lot
of engineering work that went into this
but the key piece are these two orange
boxes right here so what you're going to
do is point and click and hook up those
two files that I've uploaded previously
so here I've got a folder called uploads
that I've put these into this is where
things that are clicked and dragged and
uploaded to the same three cloud data
transfer app get uploaded to by default
so I'll hook up that first slot here and
I'll hook up the r2 to the second spot
and then I click
run so that's all there is to it and I
mean we have a few parameters that you
can adjust here but we don't recommend
we have very same defaults so we don't
recommend that you go in there unless
you followed the user guy you know want
to set something custom so once you kick
off a job I've already done this
previously and you can go into the
monitor tab and see however my job's
doing did they failed
are they still running how much did they
cost you can see this is very reasonably
priced for calculating all of these gene
fusions in an AC example and it looks
like everything was good if I really
wanted to I could click through and look
at the logs for each of these runs but
you know for the purposes of this demo
I'm not going to do that so um you're
told you uploaded your data you ran the
tool waited a few hours and now it's
done so let's take a look at some of
these results files we've got a bigwig
file that's output we've got the aligned
BAM file from star we've got some
fusions I'm gonna get in on this one
result file here which is called the
diffusion viewer so all tools in st.
Jude cloud we aim that that there's a
really nice interactive visualization
that you can use to analyze your results
rather than just a tab delimited text
file or an excel file so let's load this
up so what I've got here is a view
showing all of the putative fusions
found in this RNA see sample so if I
click there on the hot these are sort
the results are sorted from what the
tool thinks are the the fusions that you
should look at first down to you know
things that maybe you should read
through but the tool doesn't think are
as important so we have a bunch of high
quality in frame fusions here and for
the student view you'll notice that
there's the BCR Abel fusion here and
there's a nice view of the protein
that's been formed here I can toggle
this chimeric view and show a nice you
know what the byproduct of this fusion
is now also you'll notice that the
tyrosine kinase domain is preserved in
this example so it's really neat it's a
nice way to go through
look at the different fusions that are
produced so so yeah so with that I think
I will hand it off to Scott again just
to go through the visualizations and st.
you cloud you're back with me Scott so
clay just showed you how you can run a
st. Jude tool on your own data but how
about if you want to run a novel
analysis something that we might not
have a tool for on our data or indeed on
your own data within the cloud ecosystem
the new mantra is becoming bring the
tools to the data because the data from
whole genome sequencing is huge whereas
the tools are relatively small and as
I'll show you in the next couple of
slides it's actually quite easy to port
your tool and I think a programmer of
quite average abilities such as myself
can quite easily do this so here's a
simple demonstration hopefully you all
heard of the popular RNA sequence
ocation tool HTC published by anders
pile and uber in 2015 what you do is
give this tool a BAM file of mapped
next-generation sequencing reads you
give it a GTF file that you can download
from ensemble or UCSC which defines your
gene model and it will count the number
of reads that overlap with your gene
model features so here's just a simple
program that I've written that I run in
our local compute cluster on the first
line you define the name of your BAM
file test file dot BAM and the next line
you derive the name of that file bam
name then you define the name of your
output your bam file name plus HTC txt
and then you define your gene model GTF
refseq GTF and you run the command HTC
count F I'm giving it a BAM file I'm
telling it position s no you don't have
to worry about these parameters and I
pass it the BAM file and GTF file and it
will output this is probably the
simplest bioinformatics
you'll ever see but how do I move that
from my local computer into the cloud
what you have to do is define your
inputs and outputs in a JSON file which
is a popular format to transfer data on
the web and you give your tool a name
you tell it what your vamp file is going
to be called you tell it what your GTF
file is going to be called just like I
did previously you tell it what your
output file is going to be called then
you load your GTF file into a secure
one-off instance inside of DNAnexus you
load your BAM file on your GTF file and
you run the exact same HTC command as
you did before you then output the data
so really all we're doing is wrapping a
single line of codes in the DNAnexus
framework now for the non programmers
out there you may find this this to be
quite challenging and there is a little
bit of a hump to get over but I think
you need a relatively low skill level to
be able to do this for the
bioinformatics professionals you might
be listening and I hope you'll agree
that this is quite a straightforward
procedure of course what I've
demonstrated is just the tip of the
iceberg and that the outcome is actually
you now have an htc tool that you can
deploy the cloud using a simple DX build
command and it appears here in the st.
Jude cloud DNAnexus style project as st.
Jude htc and you can then run the tool
with a simple click you no longer have
the program at the command line all you
need to do is to written the code on the
previous page and that tool is now there
for you to use the added bonuses you can
now share that tool with your lab
members or collaborators that might be
anywhere in the world just by granting
them access to your project and it's our
hope that this system is is simple
enough for non-specialists to learn and
it should be easy enough for the
bioinformatics scientists to learn
there's lots and lots of other
complexity that you you may wish to
introduce for example and DNA
next is now offering common workflow
language and workflow definition cwl and
widdle support if you you want to move
pipelines from other platforms and as
well as support for docker containers
parallelization etc it's all in there
and it's all very well documented and so
that's all I want to say about tools and
lastly you don't have to be a
bioinformatics wizard to use this thing
absolutely anybody can explore the data
the visualization sections of st. Jude
cloud has a need to make simple
intuitive and interactive visualizations
that anybody who's interested in in
cancer genomics or some of the other
diseases we study to make novel insights
from the data visually and with that
Mouse you don't need any programming
skills and many of these visualizations
have been linked to high-profile
publications and we've made the data and
the visualizations available but I'd
like to zoom in on our new one and this
is a software we are calling genome
paint and it is a new genome
visualization engine powered by protein
paint and changers visualization team
here at st. Jude I'm gonna hand it over
to clay and he can walk you through p53
and some interesting mutations as
visualized through genome pain all right
so last but not least visualizations so
you can go to you can click on the
visualizations tab from the phone front
page and this is where it will land you
we have a bunch of different study study
level visualizations which I'll get to
in a second but I'm going to key in on
this PC GP somatic and germline
mutations so what we've done for the
pediatric cancer genome project is we've
taken all of the variants that we have
that and we put them into one view for
you to kind of browse and see if any of
the any of the data here can help you in
your own studies so first up we've got
some a taxi tracks to hint at possible
regulatory regions we've got the copy
number of variants
in pc GP we've got some cosmic hotspot
mutations and then we've got PC GPS some
of the somatic mutations and then the
germline variants called by the
Microsoft genomic service so down here
at the bottom we have a very extensive
filter view all the ways you might want
to slice and dice this data so what I'm
going to do for the purposes of this
demo is go through and filter only the
pathogenic or likely pathogenic clinical
significance those that have been
reviewed by our analyst and you can see
that there are many many fewer variants
here so let's try this one
so you get a lot of information about
this and normally this is all you would
see are these information but if you
apply for access you can get down to the
genotype of each individual patient so
that's you know protected access but in
this case we have a sample here which in
the in the germline sample in this graph
you know it has a variant allele
frequency of probably about 0.35 and
then you can see it also light up over
here as it's up to around 0.75 up here
so in this case you know you might
examine this and say hey that looks
similar to a loss of heterozygosity
event in this sample things like that so
there's a lot of really cool things you
can do I'd encourage you guys to go out
there and explore this give us your
feedback things that you would want to
see in this additionally we have these
study level visualizations so frequently
when we publish papers we will have a
place to come and interactively view the
data so um let's try this one the recent
study by Chang ways group right so so
here we have there's a lot to go into
about what this can do you can open up
things about what kind of variants are
here and what genes are affected in
individuals but I'm just going to click
around and kind of show you that we
group different mutations here based on
the disease type and it looks like the
gene that's affected there's a lot of
cool things you can do it's very
interactive and sortable so you can see
me clicking on
things and seeing sorting based on what
of the genes of interest often we have
metadata at the top here about you know
sex or age of diagnosis or a number of
other things so again I would encourage
you to go to the visualizations page
check it out see if there are any
publications you're interested in and
let us know if you have feedback so with
that I'll turn it over one last time
it's got to finish out the presentation
Scott I'm back and so that's about
everything that we want to demonstrate
today and we really appreciate you
taking the time to view our webinar and
I'd like to close by saying what is the
future of st. Jude Cloud well as I as I
heard recently the the genome sequencing
business has entered the exponential
phase and we're generating a whole load
of whole genome and whole transcriptome
data on clinical samples and research
studies at st. Jude and we hope to be
adding those to st. Jude Cloud as the
studies are published we're on track for
ten thousand twelve genome sequences by
2019 and those will be publicly
accessible through the data access
procedure that I just outlined and we'll
be adding basic clinical data and
epigenetic data other things like gene
expression and copy number profile are
also coming soon and we'll also be
expanding into new diseases and if
you're at the American Society for
hematology and you may want to look out
for a sickle-cell study that that will
be added to say to you declared shortly
in terms of tools we're going to be
adding our structural and copy number
whole genome sequencing pipelines which
we believe are among the best in the
business and we'll be improving the
integration of our protein paint
visualizations with user data so you can
generate the same visualizations that
clay showed with your own data at some
point in your future and also there will
be several new types of visualizations
so watch this space this has been a big
complex study and lots of people have
been involved and I'd like to
acknowledge them and thank them for the
help that's all from me thank you very
much
thanks cotton clay for the wonderful
presentation we now have time for some
Q&A if you have a question like to ask
please do so now click on the Q&A button
at the bottom of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and click the send
button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is what additional
tools are you looking to the add to the
existing library on the platform and I
can answer this one singer and so what
we're aiming to make available high
quality tested error proof tools
hopefully hopefully that's the case and
we have slated as I mentioned in the
webinar copy number and structural
bearing prediction using our published
inserting impressed algorithms I also
mentioned that we are going to produce a
tool that can find mutational spectra
from whole genome sequencing data and
there been some really interesting
insights from from luekemia for example
there's a signature of UV light induced
DNA damage in in b-cell leukemias that
we don't really understand why but you
can find it using this mutational
signatures tool and the last one we have
in development is something called sis X
we're calling it you can find
allele-specific expression and so if one
allele is being expressed more than the
other and you've also found a variant
that's maybe in the promoter that might
be the evidence that the promoter is
driving mono allelic expression of that
particular gene and so all of these are
quite interesting areas that were
working in and we hope to make those
tools available to everybody not just to
use them also to improve them and give
us feedback all right sounds great our
our second question is what are the
costs associated with running analysis
on st. Jude cloud I guess I'll take this
one
okay so in terms of the cost right I
know Scott already covered that all of
the st. Jude data the close to a
petabyte of data has been sponsored by
Microsoft so you can get a copy of that
data for free if you upload your own
data to st. Jude cloud obviously there's
a storage cost associated with that so
that cost some money but it's relatively
negligible especially when compared to
you know the cost of storing things
locally and investing in Hardware things
like that with the tools it's a similar
situation right so it costs money to run
to run the tools because there's
underlying computing infrastructure
there but that cost is pretty negligible
and we hope that you know moving forward
labs will start building in the cost of
running these tools in the cloud into
their yearly budgets there is one
exception though for the tools so the
pecan pie variant annotation tool you
can just upload a VCF and st. Jude will
pay for that so I think I think that's
all of the things that cost money in st.
Jude cloud Scott can you think of any
others well I have one thing to add um
claims got a team of software engineers
she was trying to make the tools as
efficient as possible so to minimize the
cost for the users I think that's right
all right then we have another question
of how can I learn to use the st. Jude
tools that's a good question
I'll take this one to Scott if you don't
mind so when we when me and my team are
working with the biologists here and
we're developing these tools and
optimizing them one of the things that
we place a lot of emphasis on is making
sure that it's very clear how to run
them what the results are spitting out
is very clear because you know we've had
a lot of experience with fire from a
tech schools being blackbox tools so on
our documentation site we have a full
guide full write-up from the authors of
the tools and my engineers talking about
how do you run this tool how do you get
your data in there what are the
different parameters that you can input
what are the results files that come out
and and you know some gotchas about how
you might interpret those results and
all
they're like known issues things like
that so we hope that that's where people
are going to learn how to run our tools
and what our tools do but as always you
know we're trying to constantly make
improvements to that so you can always
reach out to us st. Jude cloud slash
contact and and ask questions and we'll
also be updating documentation
frequently all right it looks like we
have time for one more question any
questions we haven't had time for we
will be following up via email so for
the last question isn't this just
DNAnexus with the makeover um ok I can
answer this one and my answer would be
no it isn't um st. Jude clouds sits on
top of DNAnexus
and we're really happy with that
arrangement because the DNA Nexus
toolkit gives us security file
management workflow management all
things that scientists like me don't
care about but really have to care about
and DNAnexus does a great job of that
and all of our stuff that we've shown is
exclusive to st. Jude cloud you have to
go to st. Jude cloud to access our
workflows and our visualizations now the
other part of the story is however we
don't suppose that there's going to be
one cloud platform to rule them all
more likely there's gonna be a evolving
cloud ecosystem with all of these sites
talking to each other and the really
interesting thing is that DNAnexus
provides that ecosystem and there are
there are other places that mosaic
consortium precision fda also on and on
DNAnexus and and tools can move
relatively freely between those sub
sites and so I've said that we have our
st. Jude tools that are available
through st. Jude cloud but what I didn't
say is that there are a whole load of
other tools available through DNAnexus
platform to do many many things that we
haven't had time to implement some of
the the new variant callers for example
are available through
in excess and you can run them directly
on st. huge cloud data and so hopefully
that answers your question all right
sounds good
um so we're about out of time now I'd
like to once again thank the team from
st. Jude both Scott and clay for the
presentation any final words from either
of you no thanks very much for joining
us
yeah thanks for having us all right
thank you once again Scott and clay if
you would like any more information
about how to access the st. Jude cloud
platforms public repository or how to
utilize the collection of Buyan
traumatic stools and unique visual
visualizations email us directly at st.
Jude cloud slash contact if you're
interested in building a community
portal like st. Jude cloud for your own
research team please email info at
DNAnexus comm or visit go DNAnexus
dot-com slash community - portals for
more information before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
until April of 2019 they'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that on us with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon
enjoy